there's growing evidence that the
inequality between rich and poor
people's emissions within countries now
outweighs disparities between countries
in other words high emitters have more
in common across international
boundaries than they did 30 years ago no
matter where they call home the world
inequality lab drew on a range of data
from diet to car ownership stock market
investment and global trade to estimate
carbon output
the top 10 of polluters overlap with the
world's wealthiest 10 percent
anyone who earns more than thirty eight
thousand dollars a year
the richest one percent more than sixty
million people earning over one hundred
and nine thousand dollars a year are by
far the fastest growing source of
emissions
globally the top one percent located all
over the world with 37 in the u.s and
more than 4.5 in brazil and china
actually emit about 70 times as much
carbon as the bottom 50
so why do the rich and poor pollute
differently as people get richer diets
tend to diversify and meat consumption
rises
the average american in 2019 ate 53
pounds of beef the most carbon intensive
meat
and growing middle classes in developing
countries from china to south africa are
eating more meat than ever
far higher up the income distribution
emissions increase exponentially the
single most polluting asset the super
yacht saw a 77 surge in sales last year
and an 11 minute ride into space is
responsible for more carbon per
passenger and the lifetime emissions of
any one of the world's poorest billion
people
one tenth of all flights departing from
france in 2019 were on private aircraft
in just four hours those individually
owned planes generate as much carbon
dioxide as the average person in the
european union emits all year
four-fifths of the people on the planet
never get on an airplane in their entire
lifetime
the top one percent of emitters are
responsible for 21 of the emissions
growth since 1990 while the will's data
shows runaway emissions from a class of
individuals the top
0.1 whose responsibility is so great
that their decisions can have the same
climate impact as nationwide policy
interventions owning a car meanwhile is
one of the fastest ways to enlarge an
individual's carbon footprint suvs with
the largest contributor after power to
the increase in global carbon emissions
from 2010 to 2018. when it comes to
energy consumption the difference can be
even more stark an average person in
nigeria uses about half as much
electricity in a year as a u.s high
definition television the huge gap
between high and low emitters suggests
that the current nation-centred approach
to cutting carbon needs to be rethought
as consumers and investors the choices
of the wealthy can have an outsize
impact especially on transport and
housing
rich people need to use the full extent
of their influence if changes to happen
as role models as corporate executives
or board members
and as citizens engaging with policy
reforms